what's going on everybody welcome to the
second part of this accumulative swing
index tutorial in this video we're going
to be just calculating the entirety of
this swing index and doing it step by
step so first to do this we're gonna
need some sample data and obviously your
input of the sample data wouldn't be as
crude as this but we're just going to
make it very simple and work through it
so we need two days worth of prices
right you need open high low close from
two different days so here just as an
example one will call this this is
November 11th 2013 and we're a little
bit there we go and here we're gonna
have open one equals something high one
equals something low one equals
something and close one equal something
I had the space there and so the open is
gonna be 12
8650 will say here the high 1287 70 70
the low 1278 50 and the final close 1281
70 and that would be for november 11th
then we're going to do November 12 2013
and again we're gonna do open two equals
high two equals low two equals and close
to now the November 12th open is twelve
eighty one eighty the high was twelve
eighty four fifty below twelve sixty
seventy and the actual closed twelve 66
70 so now that we've got some sample
prices here again this is for gold the
gold is a limit move equals 75 and now
we're ready to start working with this
data based on that formula
so if I bring this image back up we see
the well we have a couple of things that
we need to establish first like these
are K and L we already established L
because it's just a simple value it's
the limit move but we still have to
establish before we can plug in this
entire formula we have to know what R
and K is so let's go ahead and tackle
our and get started there so we know
with our first we need to find out what
is the largest either h 2 minus c 1 l 2
minus c 1 or H 2 minus L 2 right so
that's the first thing we need to do so
let's get started doing that so for this
we're going to make a function we're
gonna call us to find calc underscore
underscore capital R and this is gonna
take a few parameters we need to have H
2 C 1 l 2 o 1 and the limiting price to
calculate this those are the required
things so then we're just going to say x
equals something y equals something and
the equals something
what are they can equal we're gonna
first do those calculations right so H 2
minus C 1 and then this is gonna be L 2
minus C 1 and then finally H 2 minus L 2
+ x/y/z and just for the sake of seeing
them let's go ahead and print them out
so later on we know whether or not our
logic is actually correct XY and frenzy
so now we need to we're going to call
some if statements so we're gonna say if
Z is less than X and X is greater than Y
so we can do that we're just going to
say print X wings then also we need to
establish that well in this case R
equals what is our equal well let's
revisit the picture again so with if H 2
minus C 1 right for X is the largest one
what is the formula it's going to be H 2
minus C 1 minus 0.5 times this and so on
the only thing you need to keep in mind
whenever you're reading formulas like
this is you can't do Oh point five and
then
in parentheses ins you can't do that
within Python you're gonna have to say
0.5 times this and to make it correct
you'll want to throw parentheses around
that so I'll show you what I mean in
just a second
so in this case R is going to be equal
to L 2 minus C 1 minus and then again it
was point 5 and then in parentheses you
were gonna have L 2 minus C 1
well the way you'll have to do this is
gonna be really minus 0.5 times that but
really what's meant to come out of this
would be this right so you got to make
it algebraically correct next we're
gonna do plus and again we've got that
same scenario right with 0.25 times
whatever and so we'll do the same thing
and then it's going to be C 1 minus o 1
for open one and just just for the
record make sure that you're actually
typing oh and not a zero this real easy
these for me whenever I say Oh a lot of
times I'll hit the zero key and if you
have fat fingers you can also just
straight-up typos the zero anyway we'll
go ahead now and once we've done that
we'll print out our and then also we
want this to actually return our so we
can call it call this function and this
the entire function is going to return
the answer of our right because that's
our goal we want to calculate our and
then so we'll return our so later we can
say you know R equals calc are and it'll
calculus a return R and that's a 5 it'll
say R equals calc our blah blah blah
blah that makes a 5 it'll just it'll say
R equals 5 and so that's the idea there
so now we need to do the same thing with
the other parts of this equation so L if
X is less than Y yet Y is greater than Z
we'll print out y wins and in this case
R was equal to believe it's actually
pretty similar let's look at it again so
if this is the case the only thing like
the end of the equation is the same
the only thing that changes is really
instead of high - it's actually low -
right otherwise oh it actually changes
right here as well bummer so we'll have
to we'll just copy and paste and make
those changes
so basically everywhere you've got you
know H I'm doing my best to make copy
and paste but anyway low and high would
be the way it goes so if this is the
case we'll just copy this R equals
basically the same thing only difference
is this will be I think and maybe we
might have actually done this
calculation incorrect as well yeah I
know that I look at it yeah this is
actually supposed to be a H right I knew
I was like gonna paste it sound like no
I don't think that's right so I think
this is the way we want it so L 2 minus
T 1 H 2 minus C 1 so let's pull up that
picture again right so this is H 2 then
L 2 this should be L 2 then H 2 yes
okay cool it's easy to get yourself
turned around as you can see now we'll
go ahead and just print R and then we
want to return our apparently I never
actually fully returned R up here either
so don't forget to do that up there and
then also just in case anyone's curious
the purpose of running the Elif here is
so if this statement is met it won't
even bother trying to run this statement
so it keeps your processing low so it's
the most efficient way to do it now
again we'll call another L if and this
time if X is less than Z at Z is greater
than Y well print Z wins and if Z wins R
is equal to H 2 minus L 2 plus 0.25
times C 1 minus o 1 and let's consult
the image make sure that's correct H 2
minus L 2 s H 2 - OH - yes okay so we've
done that part right so now at this
point we should have
fully functional calculation of our so
now when we want to run this so keep in
mind this is the actual function so I'm
going to copy this and we're gonna go
down here and we're gonna call this
function and and then we need to replace
all the variables so h2 is actually you
know hi to see one is close one l2 is
low 201 is open one and limit move is 75
just make sure H to see one L 201 H to
see one l 2o 175 so calc R so we could
say literally R equals calc R and then
print R so in this case we should get
the returned value of R and we need to
go ahead and finish up this part I don't
know what we're on my mind is today
return our and cool so now when we run
this we should get the output a par so
we'll save it and run it make sure you
get any errors and we can see here that
Z 1 so this was X this was why this was
Z and sure enough 23.8 is the highest
value so z did indeed win and now we
have the r value of 22.6 that is the
value of r so now that we've calculated
our the next variable that we have to
calculate that has steps to it is K
luckily we did the hardest one first
which was our since I had the most steps
to it so probably the hardest part is
complete so I'm gonna go ahead and
conclude the video here and continue on
in the next video with the next steps to
these swinging debts as always thanks
for watching